If hell is the lowest and
hottest place in America,
and heaven the highest,
then everything in between
is purgatory.
Now, dance with the devil.
From Death Valley...
to Mount Whitney.
146 miles of gross scraps...
painful naps...
and deadly traps.
This is a tale of survival...
...between two great extremes.
(music: America the Beautiful)
(music)
Here lies a valley
called death.
It's the hottest place
in America.
A fine summer's day can hit
130 degrees-plus.
It has all the desert and
desperation you'd expect.
Plants have a tenuous
grip on life.
Animals appear
just as stressed.
(music)
So, when the going gets tough,
the tough do a round
at the golf course.
(music)
It's not a mirage,
but a surreal man-made oasis,
nurtured by thousands of
gallons of underground water.
There are hazards here.
Especially for the wildlife.
Only a privileged few coyotes
are brave enough
to take a swing
at this high life.
But their rewards are
liquid refreshments.
And maybe a birdie.
(music)
Problem is, roadrunners
don't just run.
(music)
Another young coyote takes
a shot close to a water hazard.
A flock of ibis.
(music)
This lake may be the most
lethal trap on the course.
(music)
His scorecard's not
looking too good.
He may need some more
lessons from mom.
A coyote pup that
can't fend for itself
wants whatever mom brings home.
If that's not enough,
forget golf.
(music)
The pup that scored the old
deer skull draws attention.
(music)
Real flesh and bone is a prized
possession in coyote land.
To keep something
like a rabbit skin,
you gotta turn it
into buried treasure.
(music)
But a pirate watches.
There's nothing worse than
taking your eye off the ball.
(music)
The 19th hole is what
golfers call the bar.
And there's one out here
offering a top-shelf cocktail.
A single date palm tree can
produce 300 pounds of dates.
The ripest treats
litter the ground.
Their sweet smell
is a siren song.
And fruit flies answer.
But there's a problem.
After a long journey
through the desert,
they risk overdoing it.
Each date is almost 80% sugar.
Which ferments in the sun.
The results are intoxicating.
The fun fruit fly party
gets out of hand.
And this is a bad place
for a bender.
Below is a sobering sand trap.
(music)
It reminds everyone
that Death Valley
includes the D word.
This alien-looking insect larva
is called an antlion.
It digs its home
with steep walls.
All he needs is a tipsy
fruit fly to stagger close by.
(music)
One wrong step, and...
There's no escape.
The antlion's jaws
grip like a vise.
And more, they are hollow,
like syringes.
It injects powerful enzymes
deep inside its prey.
They liquefy the fly's insides.
(music)
After the enzymes are done,
the antlion reverses the flow,
sucking out every
last bit of goo.
Soon, the fly is nothing more
than an empty shell.
(music)
After ditching the evidence,
it readies itself for
the next drunken victim.
(music)
The antlion will continue
to trap its food
for years to come.
Eventually, it'll transform
into a large, harmless
fly itself.
And buzz off to discover
the harsh realities
of life beyond this oasis.
Death Valley is the lowest
point in North America,
and the hottest.
The golf course sits in the
middle of this sunbaked park.
Yet travel just 105 miles west
and you reach Mount Whitney,
the highest point
in the Lower 48,
and still rising.
The path between these points
is a journey of great extremes.
Some folks can't wait
to check it out.
Once a year, madmen and women
line up in Death Valley
to do the unthinkable.
100 athletes from 20 states
and 19 different countries
compete in perhaps the world's
most grueling foot race.
(cheering)
The Badwater Ultramarathon
is 135 miles long.
(music)
It starts at Badwater Basin,
280 feet below sea level.
Only one way to go from here...
up.
The humans are doing it tough.
Not everyone out here
is in such a hurry.
You might say this is
no country for old men.
But for one old-timer out here,
it's a different story.
(music)
After more than 40 years in
California's Death Valley...
this old tortoise has
learned a trick or two
about survival in the desert.
Like seize the shade
while you have it.
(music)
He's just a bit bigger
than a football.
And he grows less than
an eighth of an inch each year.
(music)
He forages when it's cooler,
especially in spring and fall,
and feasts on grass,
flowers and shrubs.
(music)
Even some cactus now and then.
If he's lucky, there's some
moisture in the plants he eats,
but he can also go a full year
without a drink.
(music)
He's not in any speed race.
Flat out, it takes him
around five hours
to cover a single mile.
But he is built
for off-road endurance.
Those limbs may look
a bit clunky,
but they are powerful tools,
with strong claws for
his most important duty.
He digs burrows
to escape the heat.
Some go as deep as six feet.
This trip topside is
more of an anomaly.
Desert tortoises spend
an incredible 95% of
their lives underground.
Come winter, he may share a den
with several others.
And maybe find a mate
for the spring.
Nothing escapes the sun
in Death Valley.
It defines life
from the rocky outcrops
to the fine sand of the dunes.
When the sun peaks in the sky,
the ground can exceed
200 degrees Fahrenheit,
almost hot enough
to boil blood.
That's why those
marathon runners
began in the cool
of the evening,
and now run into the dark.
It's the best way
to beat the heat.
In winter, Death Valley
night temperatures
can drop to below freezing.
But it's mid-July.
At 3:00 AM,
it's still in the 70s.
Just off the road,
other creatures of the night
also take advantage
of the temperature dip.
(music)
The desert kangaroo rat
is built to survive
in this unforgiving world.
She has special kidneys
that dispose of waste
without sacrificing much water.
And unlike all other mammals,
she doesn't sweat to keep cool.
Her ears, although small,
can detect almost
any approaching predator.
Helpful when danger glides
across the dunes.
(rattling)
They call him sidewinder,
one of the desert's
deadliest gunslingers.
He packs two fangs capable
of delivering a venomous bite.
(music)
The sand is still
painfully hot,
but this rattler has adapted.
By moving side to side
instead of slithering,
he only ever makes contact
with two points of his body
at a time.
(music)
The kangaroo rat also
gets a lot of airtime.
She can jump up to nine feet
in one hop
as she bounces through the
brush on her hunt for seeds.
(rattling)
When these two face off...
It all comes down
to the quickest draw.
(rattling)
The sidewinder is one of
the most dangerous creatures
in California's Death Valley.
The kangaroo rat,
within striking distance,
is in big trouble.
(music)
Close, but no strike.
The kangaroo rat manages
to dodge death.
Almost all of these encounters
favor her lightning-fast
reflexes.
The sidewinder looks
for another meal.
And sure enough,
at dawn he finds a second duel.
But this roadrunner
is no chicken.
Around here, she's the law.
(music)
It's fang versus beak.
The sidewinder may have
deadly venom,
but the roadrunner is fearless.
(rattling)
(music)
This hero of the West
barely blinks an eye.
(music)
And she keeps on running.
The sun rises after 5:00 AM
and so does the mercury.
Soon it's 98 degrees.
As the ultramarathon runners
pass the 40-mile marker,
many slow to a walk.
No athlete can run
135 miles nonstop,
especially in the hottest place
in America.
Runners can drink close to
a gallon of fluid every hour.
They call out for hydration.
Behind them,
the Mesquite Sand Dunes.
Here, and throughout
Death Valley,
iconic mountains of sculpted
sand hide among the landscape.
(music)
Some are more than
600 feet high
and constantly reforming.
(wind blowing)
They move with the wind.
Plants on the edges
don't survive long
once a dune moves their way.
(wind whistling)
They are a sight to behold.
(music)
And in one case, also a sound.
The Eureka Dunes near
the north end of the park
sing aloud with
a booming voice.
This is what they sound like.
(low humming and whistling)
The sand grains of Eureka Dune
are dryer
and more loosely packed
than most.
And they're mixed
with very little dust.
When they shift,
the friction between them
creates an acoustic airwave...
(low humming)
...that sounds like
a groan or a hum.
Sometimes a boom.
It's a Death Valley serenade.
Inside dunes like this,
one of the park's
best-equipped creatures
prepares to meet the day.
He uses the rays of the sun
to get his juices flowing.
And once the coast is clear...
(music)
This is the Mojave
fringe-toed lizard,
a master of desert survival.
He's got the best camouflage
in North America.
So, it's hard to distinguish
this medium-sized lizard
from the sand surrounding him.
Flaps over his ears and nose
along with overlapping eyelids
work like valves
to block pesky sand.
But his best feature
just might be his namesake.
Those fringed toes.
A special adaption that
helps him stay above the sand.
Comb-like scales
on the edge of his toes
turn this lizard's feet
into snowshoes on sand.
So he runs without
burning his feet.
He doesn't even sink
below the surface,
thus giving the fringe-toed
lizard one more advantage:
speed.
The fastest was clocked
at 23 miles per hour.
At that speed, the lizard is
almost completely on two feet.
Temps skyrocket.
The Mojave fringe-toed lizard
must call it a day.
So, he heads to the coolest
place he can find.
Where no one even
knows he's there.
(music)
Few can handle the midday heat
out in the open.
But the fringed-toed lizard
has a cousin
who is a most extraordinary
exception.
In California's Death Valley,
the desert horned lizard
must hunt when
his prey is active.
And he's picky.
He really only eats
one thing: ants.
Ants for breakfast,
ants for lunch,
and ants for dinner.
Harvester ants make up 90%
of the desert
horned lizard's diet.
But these insects are
pretty tough themselves.
And they have numbers
on their side.
(music)
Each colony has around
10,000 individuals,
and each individual packs
a painful bee-like sting.
Some ants will scurry
more than 40 yards
to collect seeds for the nest.
(music)
So the lizard has the best luck
on the outskirts of the colony
and plucks off a passerby.
(music)
But he can't afford
to fall asleep on the job.
A couple spot him
and fearlessly move in.
His scales are
as tough as nails;
fingernails that is.
Each one is like a mini shield.
But a harvester ant can
get under anyone's skin.
And then...
bite in.
It's an alarm clock with
a piercing wake-up call.
(music)
The human runners out here
are also suffering.
Most of the Badwater
Ultramarathon runners
are still going.
But at 70 miles in,
the long, hot road
to the base of Mount Whitney
takes its toll.
By the end of the race, one
quarter will have dropped out.
The option plays on the mind.
They have more than
50 miles to go
when they exit
the national park
with still plenty of desert
to endure.
Not even realizing
they're moving past a lake.
Owen's Lake.
At least this is what passes
for a lake around here.
120 years ago, water filled
this salty basin.
And towns and mines
surrounded it.
But engineers built an aqueduct
to divert the flow
to Los Angeles.
And arsenic from
the ancient lakebed
turned it into
a toxic dust bowl.
(music)
Too dangerous to inhale.
Now, to solve that problem,
engineers have turned
the tap back on.
(music)
And life is returning
with the water,
starting with brine flies.
(flies buzzing)
They hatch here in April
and throughout the summer.
(flies buzzing)
And then birds
come to eat them.
(squawking)
(music)
Gulls.
Ibis.
(music)
And a host of others
on the wing.
The natives are welcome back.
But some visitors here
are outsiders.
The miners who used
to work this area
left behind more than
waste and ruins.
They're most likely the ones
who introduced
a most destructive new species.
These are feral burros.
These wild donkeys travel
up to 40 miles a day
throughout California's
Death Valley area
in search of anything green.
(music)
They use roads, the paths
of least resistance,
to skip the rockiest terrain
and often head towards
Mount Whitney.
They're wasteful eaters
and quickly destroy plants
that take years to grow.
Worse still, the burros
are prolific breeders.
Herds can double in size
in four or five years.
Half a million burros
now roam the countryside.
Their invasion is bad news
for some residents
of the Death Valley area.
(music)
The largest native animal
in these parts...
the desert bighorn sheep.
(music)
These sure-footed nomads
comb the hillsides
for the most nutritious plants,
shrubs and even cactus.
(music)
But their main goal
is to find water.
(music)
They need to find a spring or
a water hole every three days
to survive the summer heat.
But with that,
they can climb ever higher
towards the cool mountain air.
The ultramarathon runners
have the same idea.
(music)
They start at below sea level
at the lowest point
in the United States.
(music)
Now they are at 4,000 feet
altitude and still climbing.
The mountains ahead
mark their finish line
at the base of Mount Whitney,
the highest peak
in the Lower 48 states.
(music)
Along the road to Whitney,
a host of all-terrain animals
that can handle the desert
and the heights.
Coyotes are tough enough
to hunt up here.
This is likely a breeding pair,
and they work together
to track down prey.
(music)
Not such good news for
their favorite menu item.
Desert hares are also climbers.
Some black-tailed jackrabbits
hang out
at elevations
up to 12,000 feet.
(music)
But they are best known
as desert dwellers.
(music)
And they have a body to suit.
Those ears act like
an air conditioner.
It's where they release
their excess body heat.
Those bunny ears are so good
at what they do,
these hares don't need to pant
or sweat, and that saves water.
(music)
The only thing more important
to this guy than his big ears
are his big feet.
(music)
With those coyotes
getting closer,
they're his best chance
for escape.
The chase is on.
(howling)
Black-tailed jackrabbits
are speed demons.
Not much moves faster
through the desert
below California's
Mount Whitney.
Especially when that black tail
is being chased
by a couple of coyotes.
(music)
These rabbits can reach
40 miles an hour
and zig-zag through any terrain
to throw off a rival.
If he has to, he can cover
20 feet in a single leap.
(howl)
Today, it's enough
to throw off the coyotes.
For them, it's back
to the grind.
Not all coyotes
are lucky enough
to score a luxury resort.
(music)
More often out here,
it's like this...
hot as hell,
chasing elusive jackrabbits.
You have to get water
when you can,
wherever you can.
A leaky pipe couldn't
be better.
(music)
It's also a single-drop shower.
And when the rabbits
are too darn fast,
there's always the spoils
from Highway 34.
Tourists drop all manner
of food just for the coyotes.
It's a quick feed that
does more harm than good.
She's lured close to the road.
The most dangerous place for a
coyote in all of Death Valley.
If a coyote, or any animal,
gets hit by a car,
they can expect to be mopped up
by an unsavory clean-up crew.
Turkey vultures.
Already they seem to wonder
what roadkill coyote
might taste like.
Most of them wait above
the road to Mount Whitney
with little interest
in the living.
They've chosen one of the only
trees around for a roost.
The desert conditions
are unbearable for most,
but these vultures have
a trick up their sleeves,
or rather, down their legs.
They pee on themselves
to keep from overheating.
A process called urohidrosis.
The urine is also
a disinfectant
that kills germs on their feet.
Handy when you tuck your talons
into dead things for a living.
Time for work.
Meet the vulture club.
Members climb on
thermals of hot air
that rise around
California's Mount Whitney.
The turkey vulture's six-foot
wingspan makes it look easy.
They can soar as far as 200
miles, if the wind is right.
Each turkey vulture relies on
its powerful sense of smell.
(music)
One homes in on a new scent.
A jackrabbit met
an untimely end.
(music)
The vulture does its best
to eat quickly.
Other dinner guests
are never far behind.
Their stomach acid is at least
10 times stronger than our own.
Their biggest worry
isn't fast food,
but a fast car.
(music)
Just up the road,
the snow-marked peaks
of the High Sierras
are a welcome sight for
the ultramarathon runners.
They've covered 122 grueling
miles to get this far.
(music)
Just 13 more to go.
13 miles in another world.
(music)
It's steep as they head through
the town of Lone Pine.
Some are down to a walk,
but that's better than a crawl.
(music)
With aching joints
and pounding feet,
they cross the finish line.
(cheering)
They celebrate the end
of a grueling journey
from the lowest and hottest
place in America,
to the highest and one of the
coldest peaks in the Lower 48.
The runners learn what the
animals here have long known.
Life in this corridor
is less about a race,
and more about survival.
Even the luxury golf course has
more traps than meet the eye.
Most creatures have
to fight for life.
Every day is a scramble,
where animals have
to watch each step
and beat the heat
as best they can.
The 146-mile path
to Mount Whitney
offers some relief.
But more extremes await
at the other end.
And a wrong turn
can be your last.
But survive this world,
and you know you've done
something incredible;
you've conquered the path
of two great extremes.